Valerie's with us in Tucson hi Valerie
how are you hi Dave God I tell you I
look forward to the afternoon so I have
my appointments because I know you're on
the radio and I just love your show but
anyway I my fiancee died two months ago
oh my god and we yeah and he he let
himself out or yeah it was it was pretty
traumatic
especially as I witnessed it but anyway
when were you scheduled to be married uh
well we were looking at July 17th of
this year
Wow I'm sorry thank you I appreciate
that
huh so where does that leave you well I
am left with a vehicle which I can take
care of the payments on that and I went
ahead and took over his phone and
dropped my phone number it was the
lesser of the payments and let's see his
motorcycle was taken care of whatever
was left I'm sorry what does taken care
of mean oh well all we had to do was
just turn it back in basically surrender
it and you didn't hide your name on that
loan no no no no this car loan my name
is on this car loan as well as his and
that's fine
I need a vehicle to get around I need a
vehicle to be able to get out of juice
on because I am leaving and probably
another five or six months yes okay and
how much do you all on this vehicle
Oh about 23,000 oh okay how do you make
a year
um well right now all I'm making is
student loans you don't have a job
unfortunately no and no one is hiring no
one is hiring me and it's frustrating so
they want you to have a vehicle you show
up and they don't hire you because
they're you you don't fit whatever
whatever they want and I don't
understand it and these these employers
are taking full
the fact that they have these large
pools of unemployed people but anyway
the main problem right now is we took
one in while two of his credit cards to
a credit union and we had it put on to
what we we did a balance transfer
basically we mean Haley you sign this
note I'm sorry we meaning you sign that
note as well yeah so now you have the
debt how much do you owe those guys um
about seven hundred and something yes
seven hundred dollars
yes okay and how much student loan debt
do you have um probably seven thousand
and Counting okay what are you studying
oh sure with a concentration in fire
science say again OSHA was a
concentration in fire science okay so
the thing is my fiance his parents and I
went into this credit union and they had
me fill out an application they took
over a month to contact me so I think
they're cooking the books first of all
second of all this credit union wanted
to run my credit and have me take on a
small loan to take care of his debt it's
not his debt the $700 debt you signed
for it right it's already yeah yeah yeah
you're right
it's already it's already your dad you
don't need to you don't need to fill out
an application your name is already on
it well exactly
let me just tell you that paranoid
statement was out of out of control
credit unions don't cook the books on a
700 dollar debt to try to take advantage
of you
they just want their money okay I just
want the honor why does this credit
union in particular always have a
security guard on duty you know i I've
never seen any credit unions do that and
everybody thanks do that they're a bank
I mean in a sense a lots of credit
unions have security guards on duty are
you in are you
participating in a church um a little
bit okay I think it'd be a really good
idea to sit down with your pastor and
start to unpack some of these things
because uh what we've you know you this
thing you're a human and any human that
goes through what you have been through
in the last year man it hurts and it
leaves a mark it scars yeah and it's
hard it's hard to function and to do
things exactly the right way and so I
think it's a good idea for you to sit
down unpack some of this with somebody
and a pastor is a good way for you to
start that and that'll probably help
your employability at that stage of the
game because what you've got is an
income crisis you cannot let run these
student loans up to the roof to pay car
payments on $23,000 car this is absurd
so we've got to get you making some
income even if it's waiting tables to
survive and to stop piling on the
student loans and get you down get your
car sold and get you into a reasonable
car because this car is way out of
control in your situation but I'm more
concerned about you than I am all of
that that you can sit down with someone
and that can they can unpack this stuff
with you because I mean if you were my
daughter that's what I'd tell you to do
because if she had been through that and
because it's just it's such a traumatic
thing that you have a you know a normal
person that goes through that has a kind
of a post-traumatic stress situation and
it's just meaning it's just you grieve
but the violence of what your grieving
is just so hard to walk through and so
just get with somebody that can love you
well and help you walk through some of
that stuff because you kind of feel like
right now everybody's ganging up on you
and and I understand how you feel that
way but they're not ganging up on you
and they're not out to get you and but
that comes from what you've been through
kiddo so that's my recommendation as
your old ugly uncle that's me telling
you what to do is you need to sit down
with somebody on that before you
forward in student loans and then as you
can start to get some of that stuff
stabilized then you can you know just
get some basic jobs going something to
create an income and where you feel like
you're getting some traction in your
life again I'm so sorry you're facing
this so but yeah that's that's my
recommendation is find a good pastor
that will invest some time into you
and/or a counseling staff at that church
that'll invest some time into you thank
you for the call open phones a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
folks on the stuff she's facing I mean
those are some wild stuff there but but
a lot of you listening to me
ask me questions on the on the basics of
things that she was talking about there
and you know that that call needs to be
a reminder to you this don't buy stuff
with someone you're not married to don't
go into debt with someone you're not
married to well we're getting married
I know but horrible things happen
sometimes even breakups happen sometimes
and then you own a house together or you
own a house with his parents or you've
got a note you know down at the credit
union that's left over or a car that's
left over when you're when you're
combining things and you're acting like
you're married you set yourself up for
all kinds of problems financially don't
do that stuff until you're married this
is the Dave Ramsey show